[Música]
nosotros podemos confirmar lamentable
tremendo dolor y es el país y todo el
mundo el fallecimiento dijo armando
maradona
aproximadamente a las 12 horas del día
de la fecha
pero hay que seguir así
[Música]
i
gracias a dios he tenido la oportunidad
de viajar a muchos lugares
y decía que soy argentino y lo primero
que me decía maradona eso sí de igualado
hoy creo que todos sintieron que se le
murió algo se te muere la infancia 7
murió tu mamá tu viejo 86
para de un ángel para de una él es el
amor de nápoles y los napolitanos por
diego quisieran en un luminoso aceite lo
hemos visto jugar yo lo he visto jugar
aquí en el barcelona y bueno siempre
deja muy buen recuerdo de su buen fútbol
su agilidad y su buen hacer mientras
estuvo aquí una casa señalada tenía
muchas amistades muchas venía con
nuestro comandante y algo que se ha dado
un día como que se conmemora el cuarto
necesario de la desaparición física del
comandante en la muerte de málaga cosas
que pasan que dieron naturaleza se ha
marchado el gigante
el gran del 'pelusa' el pibe de oro de
américa el pibe de los pueblos difícil
difícil
aunque llaman por teléfono y te cuentan
de que falleció diego decirnos diego no
digo no puede fallecer
el ídolo el mito la leyenda que hace que
un pueblo crea que lo que hace esa
persona somos capaces de hacerlo todos y
luego es igualdad van a en argentina
zinc creo que hace un año vio una
pancarta en argentina que decía no
importa lo que hayas hecho con tu vida
diego importa lo que hayas hecho por
nuestras vidas creo que funciona
perfectamente con lo que nos dio este
chicos pero es por foxley but this guy
que ibas
al final he tenido la suerte de decir
que decirle a él que el 86
porque todo el mundo todos los niños nos
quieren decir las cosas y yo he tenido
la oportunidad de decirle que ha sido
este como jugador
[Música]
pero llegó y se veía que estaba diego
que era un futbolista increíble y estaba
maradona que luchó un poco con todo lo
que lo rodeaba
[Música]
creo que la fifa debería retirar la
camiseta número 10 de todas las
competiciones y de todos los equipos
creo que es el homenaje más bonito que
podemos rendir al mejor jugador de toda
la historia tu eres dios y dios nunca
muere siempre seguirás viviendo en
nuestros corazones
[Música]